hi everyone my name is Kathleen O'Toole
and I'm the assistant provost for k-12
education here at Hillsdale College I
thought I'd take a minute to talk to you
about the college's involvement in
kindergarten through 12th grade
education for decades the college has
been involved in the education of young
citizens first through Hillsdale Academy
a private school here on campus and in
the last ten years also through the
Barney charter school initiative which
is an outreach effort of the college
through the Barney charter school
initiative we support dozens of
classical charter schools all over the
country we helped found them we guide
them through the early stages of getting
school started and one school has begun
we provide comprehensive curriculum and
instruction advice to teachers our work
through the Barney charter school
initiative is made possible by numerous
friends of Hillsdale College in other
words the advice and support that we
provide our schools comes to those
schools absolutely for free we receive
nothing in return for the guidance and
advice that we give them except for the
satisfaction that they're doing an
excellent job one may ask why do we do
this why is it that for ten years the
college has been flying all over the
place helping these schools get started
well there are a number of reasons but I
think the first and most important is
that through these schools were seeing a
recovery of American public education
you know a couple of generations ago in
this country the education that was
possible in American public schools was
much more substantive much more serious
than it is today in other words the
education that students were receiving
in this country two or three generations
ago was much more substantive than the
education the average American public
school student receives today students
used to learn languages they used to
study math and a much more common
sensical and rigorous way they used to
diagram sentences they used to write in
cursive and on top of that they learned
about American history in a way that
made them understand and love our
country what we're seeing in these
charter schools and in Hillsdale Academy
itself here on campus is that the
ordinary American citizen the children
of those
are still capable of doing that
excellent work if only they're given the
opportunity and that's what the Barney
charter school initiative is all about